tonight on Kitchen Nightmares Chef
Ramsey Chef Ramsay Chef Ramsay makes his
inaugural trip to Pittsburgh oh my God
where he tries to turn around a failing
soul food restaurant
[__] death Road the owner Miss Jean
is also known as miss mean look at this
[__] how can somebody mishandle bread
she yells at her staff everybody always
late uh-uh and the staff yells back you
told me not to leave my post box that is
[__] Miss Gene's philosophy is the
customer isn't always right there's a
problem with the mac and cheese no a
lady line as for her menu oh my God it's
a disaster it's drier than the Sahara
Desert and the only steady customers
that Miss Jeans seems to be the Flies
Chef Ramsay faces a massive challenge
hasn't been a robbery here as he goes
looking for the soul in this soulless
restaurant the restaurant looks like a
prison cafeteria 10 Chef Ramsay save
Miss Jean's Southern Cuisine he's all
fallen out of love or has the restaurant
gone too far south stop everybody stop
I'm done
that's tonight this is a disaster on
Kitchen Nightmares
continue to do you do it no more
who is that you serve me rotten food you
can actually kill them then wake up you
wake up shut the place down get out of
here that is amazing
Wilkinsburg Pennsylvania located right
outside Pittsburgh is home to Miss
Jean's Southern Cuisine opened by Jane
Gould a retired special education
teacher I love to cook and then when I
started doing it at my church everybody
wanted me to make food Misty you have to
cook this you have to cook that cheese
sauce is ready they're the ones that
really encouraged me to open up a
restaurant you'll love her food trust me
that Mac should be ready to come out
very good
she's the type of person that will
always help you if you're in a band or
if you need help be sure you feel better
because we don't want you working sick
but oh wow how can I explain this
she has an attitude problem if I catch
you on your phone it's considered your
15-minute break no exception unless you
fell on the floor and there's nobody in
here and you can't get up because James
like Dr Jeff or Mr have who cut the
steam tables on y'all gotta pay
attention somebody write these orders
like kindergarten students don't mean
because a lot of my staff is lazy I
don't think it I know it
you can't be standing back here in the
kitchen on your phone let me call you
back before I pick you up I mean that's
not right you just can't do that
and I have to go and tell them four or
five times you need to do this you need
to check this you need to check that all
right
there's a problem with the mac and
cheese they said it's overcooked and
they want something I don't want to hear
it
when she's dealing with the customer
complaint she could be known to get a
little bit nasty she said this is like
eating a potato chip a lady lime
sometimes I find myself in the kitchen
cooking and I have to stop and I go to
the door just to make sure no one is out
there wow I don't know what happens the
customers are gone oh man
there were several times I came in in
the morning
and she's crying
Jesus crying and then
I'm getting a frog she um
it'd be like she owes so much she's
scared
I'm really in need of help to the point
I don't
[Music]
excuse me
I don't know what I would do I don't
even know where else I would go to seek
out all I know if I put my whole life a
whole life savings
you know to see it go right down the
drain
I don't know what I'll do
[Music]
oh I say well
it's waiting for my car
Chef Ramsey Chef Ramsay hi I'm Gene
you're coming to my restaurant can I
speak to your minute please I'm supposed
to come to see you leave I got you a
pizza cobbler I need to see you a few
minutes before you get to my restaurant
okay uh let's get through there okay
geez all my whole life
all I've ever did was help someone else
let's take a seat over here and now I'm
really really in need of help first of
all how long we had the restaurants I
had the restaurant about 12 years and
before you run the business what were
you doing oh I taught disabled kids and
adults
and I did that for about 25 years tough
job it is
so coming out of that kind of role talk
to me about your restaurant what is it
the food how do you rate that on a scale
of one to ten I'm saying eight eight
yeah okay
the biggest problem is my staff
because they're trying to cook with one
hand and be on a cell phone with another
hand are taking more breaks and gospel
game talking and being late or just
don't show and it's just not helping me
keep my restaurant where it needs to be
I am in big big debt because I can't
keep enough clientele in a restaurant I
mean I am going through so much right
now I really don't know if I'm going to
make it out through the mud
I just don't have the money so every day
I do everything I waitress I'm the
manager I cook which is crazy because
that's how bad it is right now
I just really need your help I'm on the
edge I really really need help I can't
do it I can't
I I appreciate you coming here to see me
thank you for the updates
don't get upset I can't help
it's been so hard I just don't know what
to do
listen I'm here to help Miss Judy okay
okay
I totally get it okay thank you okay I'm
gonna jump in my car get back there and
I'll have a meeting with the staff come
on thank you okay
[Music]
thank you
wow it may be rainy in Pittsburgh but
there's one thing that picked me up
there's some good soul food wow
oh
my God
oh my goodness me
anyone in
hello oh my goodness
improper evidence
I'm scared to go out there
oh my God hello how are you good how are
you good to see you you too I'm Marissa
Marissa Marissa my goodness me was there
a uh a robbery last night there's
nothing in there that's our dessert
display over there
that is grim the restaurant looks like a
prison cafeteria it's just embarrassing
I mean Chef Ramsay's coming in asking
when was the robbery
Hello nice to see you my first name is
Johnny Johnny right Glad You Came good
to see you I'd like to have a quick get
together with the staff okay can you go
to the kitchen everybody out yes I will
uh without Miss Jean yes sir everyone to
the front we have a meeting come over
come over everybody come through great
and first name is chef Mike chef Mike
how are you my darling hello I'm Mrs
Chanel Chanel come over here so we all
stick together now that Chef Ramsay is
here I'm ready to talk about everything
that's wrong believe you me
um first of all Mr unique I'm seeing
this morning
the biggest problem from her point of
view was the stuff
oh my why would she blame the staff
for the problems in the restaurants
to get all the blame off of her yes yes
why would she pass the blame on to you
she
sort of an attitude problem she's just
mean me
Gene pillow the community for the last
20 years she's mean yes
she's mean to the customers sometimes
mean to the customers and employees too
I don't believe it
sometimes I thought she has split
personality wow
Jane were you just don't throw your
hands up and be like I'm leaving then
you got nice message
I mean I'm really confused
Miss Jean blamed you guys as the issue
and what you're telling me is completely
different so let me go get it
machine yes you got two seconds oh wow
um so I'm I'm a little confused Misty
you told me the big issue here was the
stuff
that's not the case from their point of
view they're saying that you have a Mean
Streak are you mean I don't think it's a
Mean Streak I'm a very serious person
they're saying that you're heavy-handed
with the customers in terms of the way
they've been treated
because there's a young man that comes
in here and he's like me and James I'm
grandson right it's not like my grandson
well I'm just saying Gene he's a regular
and um he ordered pepper steak and rice
one time and he just told me she was a
little salty and she said don't eat it
wow he's one of the guys that come in
here and his pants is hanging to here we
try to catch those guys when they come
in and ask him to please pull their
pants up especially on a Sunday with all
the church folks and the older ladies
and stuff okay I appreciate that having
the pants pulled up on Sundays in front
of the church Congress but whether he's
got these pants around his ankles he has
a rights he had to complain about salty
food let's get that clear yeah yeah
who's right who's wrong he's wrong
because they think I'm mean when I don't
allow them to do something that they
shouldn't do yes I do yell sometimes
because after I asked you to do
something five or six times and it's not
getting done
I think I'm too soft I need to put my
foot down if you do something and you
should be terminated
but no soft hearted me I give everybody
another chance
there's always something when I go back
there they're on their phone I mean all
gathered I've been back there when it
was five people on their phones at one
time especially you
no it's not right okay you're saying
that never happens no every time your
phone vibrates you go to the bathroom 15
times a day it goes to the bathroom I
follow her to the bathroom and you heard
me talking one time one several times
you never know what I'm following is I
drink like over two gallons of water a
day the only way you drink two gallons
of water unless you had hot pipes
uh-uh it's from the hot kitchen when
you're out drinking or whatever that
gives you hot pipes
no I can't deal with everybody's
personal problems and it's like I'm Dr
Phil
now I feel like I'm all Jerry Springer
this is serious it's not funny to me
they don't understand I am one person
and I have to deal with all of you and
I'm like really getting fed up behind it
this is crazy and everybody always late
everybody especially Mike
every single day
I'm very disappointed because I don't
feel like they respect me enough and all
these years I put into what I'm doing
this is like frustrating to me and if I
don't get Chef rams's house I am going
to lose what I have within a month's
time I really need his help
having already witnessed the major Rift
between Miss Jean and her staff Chef
Ramsay is ready to try some good
old-fashioned soul food okay
hello there you go thank you okay right
I'd like to order a few of the key
elements of any good soul food
restaurants okay first off I'll go for
the children dinner
um we don't have that available right
now no no no chitlins what a shame I had
some fried corn please we don't have
that
no sweet potato pie no mashed potato not
right now no
I don't even think we have gravy
seriously why have a menu if two-thirds
of is off
oh dear uh you got pork chops yes Bingo
let's go for the ribs okay the mac and
cheese okay let's start off with that as
a food's ready just uh bring it thank
you okay
okay ribs mac and cheese
Michael please what no playing around
wow I mean that is just like Sugar's
hair
done can I change that please it's so
sweet how much sugar goes in there I'm
not sure it's probably just poured in
there until it's sweet enough yeah
that's sweet enough right I'll just go
straight to a water please
said the sweet tea is too sweet that's
like Southern tea and they call it
that's why they call it sweet tea
[Music]
this is exercise bike it's a gym here
just no just for Mike but what's it for
for her would she
because of exercising I've never seen
anything like that wow
wow how's that doing
Jesus
did somebody sit on that what happened
it came out like that it came out like
that yes it came out like that
did did somebody sit on that no sir can
the lady not have a decent bun yes she
can she can
[Music]
um Miss Jean what is this
please tell me that the fun didn't go
out looking like I just feel absolutely
I really didn't look okay look at this
[__] today y'all be talking about it's
me
doing something out there looking like
this look at that I mean come on let me
know how do they get smashed up the
first time I don't know how can somebody
mishandle bread
whoever threw them up they don't give a
[__] they just Smash It Up Put it on the
Shelf this is what I'm dealing with but
it's not fair they don't share hot look
I don't understand why nobody don't get
it I mean come on
wow
Chanel
I just put the three together that he
should get and you want to grab
something that's the ball you told me to
get this stuff ready oh you got it
looking like a flop place you see me
wiping it off Miss Jane don't get
frustrated and take it out on me what
you have to learn you don't play food up
and hand it to somebody any kind of way
my gosh I'm so underpaid
is that for me yeah wow all right we
have the ribs and the rest okay great
how is it another weird saltiness to
them almost like they've been in a brine
would you find out and just ask them
sure you think of ribs and the
excitement
the stickiness deliciousness of it for
their very salty
he said they're salty it was almost like
they were in the Brine and nothing was
that impressive to them
they taste salty to you no this is soul
food and I really don't think Chef Rams
you know how to cook soul food just like
I wouldn't know how to make food that
British eat here's the Mac it's nice and
hot Sizzle right okay so Chanel are you
gonna start the pork chops just one pork
chop yeah one pork chop I'm scared to
cook it here's the mac and cheese
what's up man it's bubbling away can you
hear that is that in the microwave yes
for three days can you hear it crackling
[Music]
I do
elves and didn't look that good thank
you okay
depressing one thing that should always
stand out is like bloody good mac and
cheese and that's just
Bland overcooked and just Dreadful and
really bad
too too fast when you cook pork chops
you gotta stand right there and keep
turning and keep turning it Miss Jean
nitpicks you just want to tell her get
the hell out the kitchen why is it so
much smoke I don't know it might be
permanent grease damn some flew in my
eye
then I'll finish with that thank you how
is it mac and cheese well
ouch there's Bland there's no seasoning
and it's just cooked to help okay
he said some macaroni
Bland
tasting as we all grow
I'm not gonna see the macaroni is not
good when it is good
job
you need another set of soap no that's
fine thank you sweet
sad face honestly come on
how [__] depressing is that
are you serious could y'all please come
look at the pork chops please
he got it sitting up
let me think the map of America
son of the East Coast California where
that little dark spot is from the
central Midwest and we have Seattle
we're here
Pittsburgh
God Bless America
[__] flight
Chanel did you taste it if you gotta
stand up that mean it's too hard I'm not
too cool
okay so I see you at a chance to taste
the pork chop and uh what did you think
yeah dry like um a mouthful of sand
let's dry the Sahara Desert all right
even the Flies no longer interested okay
is there anything else you wanted me to
get for you or I will for that bike out
there that way I can get the [__] out of
here
oh
[Music]
he said that this was dry like a mouth
full of sand he said even the Flies no
longer take interest in it
is it dry
I still stand by my food
because I put all I have into it and I
work hard
[Music]
oh dear Tara Tara
my lunch was a joke
and anything connected to Seoul passion
heart
you've all fallen out of love
I mean how can a soul food restaurant
miss the Staples no red beans no Black
Eyed Peas no mashed potatoes the ribs
salty I mean a real weird saltiness
because it's like season them up you
season them up so they're salty and then
the sweet is anything with that barbecue
sauce on there and then the pork chops I
mean I was holding out for the pork chop
it was dry the mac and cheese I mean it
was just disappointing I think it was
good
I think the mac and cheese is [__]
disgusting what I don't chef
come on you know the macaroni and cheese
we haven't had any complaints about it
yet no because you have no customers my
darling that's why we don't we don't
have anything that's why
and you want my help
get a grip
foreign
[Music]
I told Chef Ramsay I do wear a lot of
hats
and I feel like
if you don't like my fried chicken and
you don't like my macaroni and cheese
then you know what Chef Ramsey can do he
can wear one of my hats and that's one
of them
that's how I feel
it didn't take long for Chef Ramsay to
see that Miss Jean is in denial about
her food I'm telling y'all that I'm not
gonna see him be embarrassed tonight
y'all might as well get it right now
it's time to see how this restaurant
functions in a dinner service
welcome to Gene Southern Cuisine I love
Ramsey how are you my brother how are
you this is a I'm a meal yeah I'm the
host I mean you see me today excellent
um and that looks like it's the waiting
room a doctor's clinic okay
don't you think does it look in fighting
I feel like I'm about to get my tooth
pulled
oh
I'm sorry excuse me how are you bro now
are we looking at a uh root canal issue
[Music]
will you come with me yeah good luck oh
my God it is a mess
the doctor will see you now
holy [__]
oh man it's funny all right and how are
you folks doing today drama rice I'll be
your server I'll do the ribs you're
gonna have the fried pork chops okay all
right Mike how are you okay so so orders
come in where do the orders go the slips
when the orders come they put them on a
magnet
on there oh I've been that refrigerator
Chef so you just you just you just stick
them on there that's it yes yeah wow
this is just insane all right cause
Chanel this is what we're gonna do we're
gonna get these orders out of here okay
Follow My Lead okay no we're all doing
our own tickets
[Music]
because we get confused when we share
the same tickets I'll do a ticket you do
a ticket I'll do a ticket we can't do
the same ticket we got to get the orders
out no calm down orders need to go out I
worked in quite a few restaurants I've
never seen a restaurant run like this in
my entire life the kitchen staff doesn't
know how to run a kitchen and I don't
think that Miss chain fully knows how to
run a restaurant so the end result is
just complete another chaos catfish is
up oh Lord somehow this disorganized
kitchen has managed to get the food out
unfortunately
the customers are finding little to
cheer about is everything okay
the pork chops feel like they've been
cooked for like five
hours pork chops were overdone I mean
that's just uh Man soul food I want to
sell that on [__] death row food is
not coming out right we need the food to
get out here let's go no more [__]
let's go
so depressing damn I said yeah you
really do need a job I mean like I'm
broken
[Music]
any reason why not interested uh well
because there was no customers out here
yeah just asking if she's right staff
don't give a [__] and they're always on
the phone I walk out and you're on your
phone oh she's talking about the people
in the kitchen oh no I'm talking about
you you got my phone yes I'm guilty yeah
there you go everyone get straight to
the point okay um so why do you think
it's necessary to be on your phone in
the middle of service
working
at casino
[Music]
wow I can see out the window Chef I can
see out the window
[Music]
did you get a shift in my hand first at
me did you hear it yeah he came on he
said I'm doing your cell phone he said
you just don't give a [__] that's yes I
do I said there's nobody else
second time on your phone no no no no no
right now this lady has got the world on
the shoulders and the first thing she
told me this morning was the fact that
her staff are on the phone whilst the
dining room is full
and you've been on there twice now it's
so unfair for you to go back on your
phone I'm a volunteer let's make that
very clear even if you volunteer you
have to follow the rules I mean I'm I
can't be up here to see what you guys
are doing
I told you if you needed help in the
dining room I'd be happy to do that
there's two people
not to leave the front it's what she
wasn't here that is not true and that's
[__] that is [__] you going home
yes bye bye
yeah she can she can do it she can do it
all I'm done
painting with chicken wings please just
a minute let me get somebody to read
again bye
[Music]
that's what I'm saying Chef I can't be
everywhere they know that to do that and
they do it anyway they don't care they
know better they know I tell them that
all the time can I get you guys some
more sweet tea
do you want me to take it back yeah I'll
get you guys some new ones okay okay
guys oh no what's wrong the chicken was
dried oh my God chef Mike how old is
that is that left over from lunch yeah
that's the old Chef how does chicken get
that dry guess from being under that
light show
foreign
but you're just [__] yourselves
you don't need me to tell you that
you're completely upside down you're
starving lunchtime chicken and it's dry
who's paying for this Mike
[Music]
and do you have extra money to do this
no I do not I don't know and I mean it
has to stop it really has to stop you
all really have to learn to follow the
instructions it's just that simple
you gotta have that passion for the food
you cannot continue to send food out
like this because it's my ass on the
line with my ass on the line
nobody else
the restaurant is falling apart I can't
afford it this is my whole life
this is all I have and it's going to
hell I mean it's it's pain it's killing
me
it's tearing me apart to know this is
happening
I can't continue doing no more
foreign
[Music]
I can't be everywhere I can't be at the
front desk watching people on the
telephone and I come back here my food
is not going out right I can't do it by
myself
after a dinner service that is fraught
with problems with the staff you going
home yes bye bye and the kitchen you're
serving lunchtime chicken and it's dry
Miss Jean has reached her breaking point
I can't continue to do it no more
thank you
[Music]
all right all right come on strike keep
the stronger keep it strong come on
now you know I got your back
God loves you and so do I he come here
to help us a week it's like we almost
can't even be
[Music]
out sit down
tough day yes yes Gene I totally get it
I feel for you but
the system is horrendous it is yet no
one seems to care I don't care I care
yeah
but we have to work together and I need
your help and I'm willing to like I said
I'm willing to do whatever but sometimes
it becomes hard when I really
say I need you to do something and it
doesn't get done but the system they're
working against
is yours and the system is bad
let me tell you
tomorrow I want to see a bit of an
effort okay the three of you together
okay good night
and I'll see you tomorrow okay
[Music]
in the community of Wilkinsburg Miss
Jean's reputation has been tarnished
good morning please take a seat and
before Chef Ramsay can move forward with
any changes to the restaurant he needs
Gene to fully understand this issue okay
Miss Gene there's a lot of love for you
in your community yes unfortunately
that's positivity is not shared
by everybody so this time for the world
premiere
of the other side
of Miss Jean
roll it guys
[Music]
we just had a really bad experience
she's not really customer oriented she
doesn't care she needs on her attitude
attitude she's me I told her I'll never
come in here and I won't send none of my
customers in there to you ever again
because I don't deserve this to be
treated like that
Miss Jean remember this it takes years
to get a customer that takes a second to
lose one and you've lost one to me
wow Gene how'd you explain this
you have a tendency to talk to your
customers the same way as you talk to
your staff and as soon as anyone in the
business stops respecting their
customers it's time to close the doors
and if you don't they will close your
restaurant for you
there needs to be an attitude adjustment
but not just by Miss Jane by everybody
my big question to you are you prepared
to change
are you committed yes yes sir Miss Gene
yes chef good I am anxious to make some
substantial changes
okay see you shortly okay
hurt I had no knowledge that these
people felt that had been mean to them
I want to make it right and I will fight
to make it right
with Miss Jean now realizing the damage
she has done Chef Ramsay moves on to
repairing her reputation he has gathered
former diners and now it's up to Miss
Jean to do the rest I appreciate all of
you being here and I want to apologize
for anyone that have been in my
restaurant and haven't been treated nice
by me because I really appreciate you
from my art and I can't do it without
you I really really need you
[Music]
and I'm gonna guarantee you will not be
served without a smile
you're looking at the new Miss Jeans I
was given another chance to make it
right with my customers and I'm just
I'm just so happy I'm so happy okay I
love you guys
coming up where the hell is Marissa Chef
Ramsay relaunches Miss Jeans I want to
leave but with Miss Jean and her staff
be able to handle the numerous changes
this is a disaster it's a night that is
teetering on disaster stop everybody
stop
with Miss Jean's reputation already on
demand in the community Chef Ramsay
moves forward with one of his biggest
makeovers ever
good morning good morning chef ladies
are you ready to see oh my gosh the new
Miss Jeans Southern Cuisine let's go
come in please
oh my God
it's a Miracles
wow come on
[Music]
now this place is gorgeous it is
gorgeous oh my gosh gone are those green
cold walls now we have that nice
attractive warm gray it's bigger warmer
it's just beautiful inviting we're
stunning murals etched onto the walls it
gives the restaurant warm personality it
doesn't look like a robbery anymore look
at the hand crafted tables made out of
reclaimed wood from a local bar and that
very picture there that's the barn with
these new tables you've now gone from a
45C direction to a 75 Cedar Restaurant
more importantly this restaurant has
souls
foreign
[Music]
this is like a dream come true I mean
it's a real dream come true
how beautiful is this oh my God oh my
goodness me stay
what's that we have look what we have
yeah
we go along with the dramatic change to
the look of the restaurant take a menu
please okay thank you ladies come in
please Jeff Ramsay has come up with an
equally dramatic change to the food take
a look at that presentation is beautiful
you think of soul food and the message
it sends out comfort and a bit of fun
yes it does and the good news is
everything on the menu tonight is
available please stop all right amazing
let's start off the top here
pervertisers catfish po boy oh my gosh
dressed in a French roll next night
you've got the barbecue pulled pork
sliders with fresh coleslaw all right
following on the entrees slow braised
oxtail absolutely delicious next to that
it wouldn't be soul food unless we have
catfish blackened or fried yes one more
little thing we have stunning New China
courtesy of Niagara China beautiful
wonderful great again have a little
taste I don't even want to start
[Music]
I didn't feel like she ever actually
could cook this soul food but Chef
Ramsay has proved me wrong about cooking
it just shows I could be wrong sometimes
I don't know what to eat next I know
wow I think the new food is very good
these are good
delicious
oh my goodness
[Music]
who would ever thought they put
watermelon with red onions
Miss Jeans now looks and feels like a
new restaurant and there is a buzz in
the town everybody wants to check out
the relaunch including the town's mayor
okay yes this is your table it's a lot
different isn't it I love the tables for
tonight's dinner service Chef Ramsay has
reorganized the kitchen and has put Miss
Jean at the helm as the expediter when I
yell out to yell back so I know you guys
yes ma'am yes ma'am let's see what you
got money Mike okay first order
are they dip Tilly Fried Green Tomatoes
let's go spread the Mayans perfect Step
Up all right how long on the fried green
tomatoes Fried Tomato be up in about two
minutes table two I need two sliders
fried tomatoes dipped poppies this
kitchen that never had a system before
is adapting well looking good looking
good flatters up and appetizers are
making their way quickly out to the
dining room damn that's a nice
presentation
oh my God
that sounds good
meatloaf one jambalaya oh my gosh I need
these orders out Marissa table 12's
ready Marissa table three come on guys
food's getting cold while the kitchen
seems to be pushing out food there's a
lack of coordination between Miss Jean
and the front of house
like this is frustrating all your orders
was ready right there it's just hard to
breathe whenever you just hear your name
being called
it's like I'm getting ready to leave I
can't take it we work first to sit down
[Music]
I'm ready to go
Matt's getting patient guys yet let's
not screw up now Miranda I can't take
this I really just can't
I keep getting yelled at I'm so busy
this is a disaster I don't even put that
camera on my face I want to leave stop
everybody stop everybody
I'm so stressed out and I keep getting
yelled at this it's relaunch night
and server Marissa is having a difficult
time this is a disaster and our tables
are beginning to suffer
my face stop everybody stop everybody
Marissa
calm down a minute it's new to all of us
we have to work together and this is the
way that we have to communicate in order
to get everything out you're going to be
fine okay you know I imagine a chef
wasn't here helping us do this no no
just be you oh you're gonna be okay my
name was getting called in like this is
a good thing we just got to work
together
let's go come on let's go you'll be
alive for the first time tonight I saw
Miss Gina's leader she's doing her job
to help her employees get through it the
best that she can fried chicken and the
other sale I'll be right back
with this time
[Music]
enjoy everything because you know what
I'm loving it I am feeling terrific
I am feeling so wonderful I'm loving it
I'm loving it I'm loving it come on guys
we're almost there we rolling we rolling
I'm real proud of Miss James I'm
surprised that Miss Jane she used to
make you not want to do it but tonight
she's home she got a smile on her face
that's not the best Jane I know
let me tell you something tonight we
made a major transformation in this
restaurants and you Miss Jean you handle
the pressure and turned it into
something positive thank you sir miss
mean has left the building yes
yes hallelujah thank you
the wonderful things that Chef Ram today
in the field
up right now come here let's say goodbye
he made me just feel like just going on
and I could just conquer anything now I
am gonna I wouldn't give this up for
nothing in the world you are an amazing
lady you're a very special person I'm
rooting for you thank you I am so thank
you Chef I'm just like I'm overwhelmed
thank you so much I'm not gonna let you
down look up I will let you down thank
you and take care thank you oh the
greatest
let me tell you rarely in my life now I
met any individual with a bigger heart
as Miss Jean yes she lost away but I
strongly believe right now she's on the
right track my only wish is that her
staff are there to support her
wow Miss Jean no more mean
thank you
in the days that followed the mayor of
Wilkinsburg honored Miss Jane for her
years of service to the community it is
my honor to Proclaim this Miss Jean
today June 3rd and for this day forward
I am very grateful and I thank all of
you from the bottom of my heart I thank
you
the soul is back into Miss Jean's new
restaurant and Chef Ramsey I thank you
from the bottom of my heart
[Music]
next time on Kitchen Nightmares Chef
Ramsay meets a husband and wife team who
have lost their passion not just for the
restaurant but for each other as well
there's an indent on the couch from
where he sleeps the kitchen is
disgusting look at the mess of this
place and the staff is ready to muting
doesn't know what the [__] he's talking
about find yourself a new bar manager
can Chef Ramsay pull these owners heads
out of the sand so we'll [__] man up
and save the restaurants and their
marriage you can solve this close the
shop
[Music]
thank you
foreign